in Auckland there was some talk that
maybe Derek Carr was the weak link on
the offense there and then maybe the
Raiders would change quarterbacks this
offseason they worked out Cuyler Murray
and Dwayne Haskins before the draft
Derek Carr seemed to notice it with a
social media post where he was doing the
I'm watching you gesture while he was on
the field he said yesterday though that
he knew all along the Raiders were not
going to get rid of him here's Derek
Carr from Tuesday the owner the GM the
head coach and the quarterback I don't
know about other places but here we're
all on the same page I talked to all
four of those guy all three of those
guys all the time they tell me good bad
and ugly like we are always on the same
page because that's what our team needs
that's what the good organizations do
I'm not going anywhere this is my team
and it will be for the next however long
I want to play yeah tell you what the
Carr family's been making some strong
statements this week Derek David Carr
said that Joe Montana is not one of the
top 10 quarterbacks at the Superbowl
era I think what Derek Carr said
yesterday is even more outlandish
because ask any franchise quarterback
you don't get a lifetime contract and if
you're not worried that at some point
you're gonna get thrown overboard that's
when they're about to throw you
overboard because it happened to Peyton
Manning it happened to Brett Favre Aaron
Rodgers thinks is gonna happen to him at
some point Tom Brady has been motivated
for 20 years because of the fear it's
gonna happen to him you can't make a
statement like that because the moment
they find an upgrade I mean mike Mayock
said it you have to evaluate all these
positions because if you do find
somebody better you have to go with that
person sherene well I don't think
there's any doubt that this is his team
this year when you look at the backups
they have on that roster the Nathan
Peterman's and Landry Jones and Mike
Glennon's he is the quarterback for this
team this year no doubt about that but
if he has another mediocre type season
the Raiders bring him back next year do
they start looking ahead and go this guy
isn't our franchise quarterback this
guy's had one good year and granted it
was an MVP type of year but he's got to
reproduce that and he hasn't in a while
so they need him to step up and play
like he did a few years ago at that MVP
level to know that he is their
quarterback it is his team going forward
because I think it's a one-year thing
right now I agree with you and as he
gets deeper and deeper into that
contract he signed at the Tommy's side
he was a highest-paid player in NFL
history at 25 million per year it's much
easier to walk away from him next year
than it was this year it gets easier
after that and and I think it's it shows
no understanding of how the NFL works to
suggest that you're gonna be the
quarterback of a team for as long as you
want to be that is simply not how it
works in the NFL and anybody who's been
paying attention knows it and we've been
paying very close attention to the
dynamics of the Raiders they've added
Antonio Brown this year and Antonio
Brown wasn't present for the first day
of OTAs now Sheree and I struggle with
this all the time because it is
voluntary and and I've said and I'll say
it again all play I think all players
should stand up and walk out today a
mass walkout would get the owners
attention it's a way if the players can
exert leverage they have the right to do
it it's voluntary and they should use
that power however if all your teammates
are there and you're that you're the new
kid and you're trying to establish
yourself and you've got to have the
right relationship with derrick karr and
you've got to figure out how he throws
passes and and how you have to run your
routes in order to be in position to
catch the passes I don't know why in the
world Antonio Brown wouldn't be there
for the start of OTAs after all of the
problems he created on his way out of
Pittsburgh you would think he would be
doing everything in his power to ensure
the best possible transition to his new
team you know Mike when I wrote this
yesterday this this post about Antonio
Brown not being at the team's OTAs I'm
with you I struggle with it but I
started listing all the players who have
missed part of the offseason program or
all of the offseason program that list
is long of star players and it's getting
longer every year and I think one thing
that hasn't been talked about enough so
now we're up to two things that haven't
been talked about enough but it's that
the NFL negotiating committee has talked
about moving these OTA dates to the
start of training camp and I think
that's a really good idea I don't know
why we need the this long long offseason
guys do fine training on their own you
know make it shorter and I think that's
what we're headed toward are these days
are going to be at the start of training
camp in the next CBA
yeah but here's the concern
if you thrust guys into these OTAs and
they haven't had that break-in period
then you know I look the coaches want
more time not less time and I I
suggested that they should just go ahead
and bargain for these to be mandatory
and then we take this issue off the
table altogether and and I mean they're
already essentially mandatory even
though a lot of players are staying away
most of them do it though for
contractual reasons and I'm again I'm
fine with that
but there are certain situations where
there's Odell Beckham in Cleveland
Antonio Brown in Oakland you're trying
to get off on the right foot with a new
team and back to Derek Carr
Shareen I'm convinced if Antonio Brown
doesn't work in Oakland it's not going
to be his fault it's not gonna be John
Burton's fault it's gonna be Derek cars
fault and Derek Carr is the guy remember
that the video of Antonio Brown coming
to Derek Carr's house and they're
hugging and all this cars the guy who
should be constantly texting and calling
Antonio Brown saying buddy I need you
here every day we need to be working
together as much as we can that we're
only going to go as far as the two of us
can carry us and ultimately car is only
going to be the quarterback beyond this
year if he can get the most out of
Antonio Brown yeah no question about
that and we saw Antonio Brown show up
before actually he'd even sign orbit
actually been traded because the trade
happened before the trade deadline and
they showed up and threw at the park
there in Oakland and you thought okay
he's going to be around and be around
this team a lot and he hasn't been and I
do think that's important having said
everything I said about these OTA OTA is
moving if you're a new player and you're
coming to a new team to me you probably
need to be there to get to know your
quarterback especially at the receiver
position what he likes let him know what
you like if there is a transition period
and I think these guys need to be
working and working hard on that because
you're right
Derrick futures is tied a lot to how
Antonio Brown performs and how he gets
the ball to Antonio Brown
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports